the contemporary Internet is based on a
fundamental lie we all are told that its
social we're all told that in aus
connectivity allows us to create
community but the reverse is actually
true it's atomizing us it's not creating
real community it's actually separating
us from people of different opinions of
different cultures it's increasingly an
echo chamber effect where we're only
ever connected with people who agree
with us in the first place but even more
troubling these social networks aren't
really social they're platforms for the
self that perhaps for their platforms
for us to build brands the clearest
manifestation of this is our obsession
with the selfie the selfie becomes the
cultural form of the internet wherever
we go we picture ourself in front of
mausoleums in front and as they say in
the book in front of people committing
suicide at Auschwitz at every imaginable
place in spite of all the bad taste
associated with it we are in our minds
at least our deluded Minds the center of
our universe I argue again in terms of
progress that we've gone back to a a pre
Copernican understanding of the universe
where everything of a revolves around us
there's nothing social about that and
the end consequence is twofold firstly
we're making complete fools of ourselves
that narcissism that indulgence is
embarrassing and in the long run we're
going to regret it both as a species and
individually when we look back at those
absurd photos of ourselves where we're
shamelessly exposing our own
self-importance we're going to be
severely embarrassed by it but secondly
it also reflects the reality of the
Internet it's about the individual it's
not about the social and the Internet is
alienating isolating fragmenting
ourselves it's weakening community
that's of course the reason why it
hasn't generated real political
movements it creates explosions the Arab
Spring Occupy but no legacy no political
parties no movements no real foundations
of political change